two planes collide at the north las
vegas airport killing all four people
involved this all happening at about 12
noon on sunday while the ntsb and the
faa continue their investigation we're
now learning more about one of the
victims madison kimbrough has more four
people dead sunday afternoon after two
small single engine planes crashed while
one of them was preparing to land at
north las vegas airport and we now have
learned that one of those four was
47-year-old zach rainey the father of
two was learning to become a pilot and
flying with a flight instructor at the
time of the crash a gofundme page was
set up monday afternoon in rainey's
honor to help his family with funeral
expenses while it's still unclear which
plane he was in the federal aviation
administration confirming that a single
engine piper pa-46 and a single-engine
cessna 172 collided on the runway the
piper crashed into a field and the
cessna caught fire and fell into a water
retention pond people who live in the
area near north las vegas airport say
this crash furthers their concern for
their own safety as planes are
constantly flying by throughout the day
the smaller ones are a little more
dangerous because i don't think they
have as much supervision over them for
the maintenance and stuff
and you don't know if the pilot's not
experienced or not according to the
aviation safety network the cessna 172
is registered to benner enterprises llc
which is registered in henderson in a
statement released by matthew benner the
president of air work las vegas he says
quote our thoughts and prayers are with
the families of those involved in
yesterday's terrible accident this world
lost some great people and aviators we
are currently cooperating with the faa
and ntsb to help them with their
investigation